all right guys we are back in Chinatown
in Singapore for another night
photography test and night video test
hitting against
the xiaomi 13 Pro is
the iPhone 14 pro Max that's right these
two bad boys are going up against each
other tonight in Chinatown who will
reign supreme
I kind of know but you guys don't but
you'll find out the end of this video
let's talk about it all right first
we're going to start with front-facing
camera video
4K 25p iPhone 14 pro Max working I'm
talking looking good got a little bit of
a diffusion because I've got a
fingerprint on the camera
that's a little bit of a tip or trick
for you there you want a little bit
diffusion just rub your fingertip on top
of it saves you from having to buy a an
extra
accessory that's what it looks like
decent dynamic range looking good now
I'm gonna do the xiaomi 13 Pro
oh there's no 4K xiaomi hasn't adopted
4K yet in the front-facing camera 1080
30 FPS let's give this a shot looking
pretty good here right now I got to tell
you on the screen the video quality
looks really good very good
stabilization arguably better than the
iPhone 14 pro Max but again it's not 4K
it's 1080p is that a deal breaker if
you're on Tick Tock or Instagram no it's
not
but if you want to crop in or zoom in it
is a deal breaker anyway you can always
compare it let me know what you think in
the comment section below so now we're
testing out the front facing camera of
her Photography in standard photo and in
portrait mode here's the iPhone first
bam okay next one to go to portrait mode
here
portrait mode oh
quite natural I'm gonna have 5.0 now
we're moving on to the xiaomi 13 Pro
Photo mode
beautiful go into portrait mode now
let's hit that f-stop word F2 real quick
here let's go to F5 because we want to
be exactly as the iPhone was
all right guys let us know in the
comment section below which one you like
the best I'm going to tell you the
xiaomi does very good when it comes to
photography is it better than the iPhone
14 pro Max I would say there's a little
bit more HDR effect happening in the
iPhone 14 pro Max that's just me let me
know what you guys think though but I
gotta say the image quality out of the
xiaomi looks really good that Leica
color popping through giving me that
like a look
without having to pay sumalux prices you
know what I'm talking about now we are
going to go to the rear cameras this is
where it's going to get interesting Zaki
about hit a kid as he was walking behind
see that kid right there exactly you
can't hit kids you got to be careful
what do you say Zaki
there you go Zach he's sorry Jackie
sorry all right let's go try the rear
cameras now you want to see a cool trick
exactly I want to show you a cool trick
with the iPhone by the way it's a little
off topic but you're gonna enjoy this
come with me real quick here we go here
live photo
long exposure
boom you want that blurry shot
that's what you do so if you want cars
driving by on the road and get that
blurry shot that's how you get the long
exposure you gotta shoot with the live
mode on it do you know that Zaki
you knew that yeah okay maybe someone
else in the video doesn't know
so now we're going to try shooting some
neon signs here in Chinatown seeing how
the effects are with the uh the camera
system on this now I'm on the standard
uh one time let's go to two time zoom
boom decent color a lot of dynamic range
just seeing how it's popping a little
bit of an hdri but you're getting a lot
of things exposed correctly looks really
good on the iPhone now we bring out the
13 Pro how will it compare
look at these colors look at the detail
on this
oh do we have a winner here
Zachy what do you think
xiaomi when it comes to photography I
think the xiaomi is going to win
primarily they also got a one inch
sensor in this 50 megapixel cameras on
all three versus the iPhone which is
different it's 12 megapixels all
throughout again it is pixel binning but
there's something to be said about
having a one inch sensor and these
colors are beautiful look at the detail
look how sharp it is we got ourselves a
winner with the xiaomi okay let's
continue on let's go somewhere dark and
dingy Zachy how about that talking about
the iPhone 14 pro Max for a second here
right I've had this phone for about
almost eight months since the time it
launched right and I gotta tell you A
lot of people are trying to say oh the
iPhone isn't that good the iPhone isn't
good it actually is a really good system
yes it has an older camera system than
some of the newer phones out there but
it's the ecosystem it's how everything's
tied together it does make it a very
enticing offering so for someone that
does shoot a lot of video a lot of
photos and you want a smartphone that is
balanced throughout I still recommend
the iPhone 14 pro Max the xiaomi 13 Pro
and I believe the ultra from the videos
that I saw online it really excels in
photography but when it comes to video
it's slightly lacking behind the 13 the
14 pro Max obviously there's no prores
so that's going to be a little bit
different difference in a scenario there
but also just the overall quality The
Cinematic mode that the iPhone 14 uh pro
and pro Max have
um just the overall image quality I have
to give it to the iPhone in that regard
but when it comes to photography you're
going to see tonight just how good the
13 Pro is
so let's hop at it
this is not going to win any awards but
what I want to do capture here is we're
going to go past the street light I want
to capture this building here with these
dark build with this dark awning right
here I want to see how the cameras work
in a lower light situation let's do it
here again you're seeing this Green Dot
right here that's the flaring issue that
goes on with iPhone 14 pro cameras it's
something Apple hasn't really alleviated
even after the last few uh reiterations
of it I don't know if it's a lens design
or whatever it is but it's kind of a
nuisance you can't remove it in
Photoshop or Lightroom but it is what it
is looking at the image here
it pops
a lot of detail there has a nice
exposure it's going to show a lot of uh
you know even in the darker Shadows
you're going to see some details so I
got to hand to the iPhone that does a
good job again these aren't
award-winning photos I'm just giving you
a sample images to give you an idea of
how it performs
nobody said I was a magnum photographer
okay I'm not trying to be
now we're getting a little bit of that
flaring here with the xiaomi as well
there's a slight Little Dot as well so
you're getting with the street light
again not as prominent as the iPhone but
you are seeing it there
let's take a look these are really
really neck and neck here I want to say
again screens are different so you have
to look at these on the display and
we'll put these on YouTube so you guys
can see what it looks like here so
I would say that the iPhone is a bit
warmer color than the xiaomi the xiaomi
does tend to overexpose a little bit
again not a deal breaker this probably
looks a little bit more natural more
film-like more which you're going to get
out of a mirrorless camera system this
obviously got some AI coming into play
but this is what we get out of
smartphones you're going to get that
really good balance of exposure
highlight Shadows the iPhone wins in
that way all right let's move on now
what's nice about the xiaomi here with
the one inch sensor you're getting a
nice natural depth of field with that
the orange looks great the wall is a
little bit brighter a little bit cooler
in that way so the image is a little bit
overall cooler I would naturally edit my
image like this I mean when you look at
both of these images here the xiaomi
just has a much more natural look to it
I mean this uh 75 millimeter equivalent
focal length really does a big
difference yeah so overall you're going
to see that the iPhone does a decent job
again you're going to get that natural
locate that better bouquet than you are
for the xiaomi no but it does work in
some instances and I think it works on
people than it does on subjects and
that's something that we will test in
just a bit hopefully we can get somebody
off the streets who's a very nice person
who allow me to take their portrait if
so we'll show what it looks like let's
go
I can use you Zach you want me to use
yuzaki I'll use Zaki I'll use you Zaki
Zaki wants to have a photo taken for his
IG that he never posts up
I take all these photos of Zaki never
uses any of them
I feel so used
that's a look Zacky
got it okay now we're going to the
iPhone
exciting time Zacky exciting times
torture mode this is the look you gave
me Zaki
look at that look it's a close match I
gotta say though I would give it to the
xiaomi in terms of looking a little bit
more natural the iPhone is very very
close though in terms of trans O'Hara
things that are going to come out of
when somebody's you know head the iPhone
probably won't catch it as much as the
xiaomi does but in a situation like this
I'll give the edge to the xiaomi just a
slight Edge though slight all right Zach
is we're moving on to the temple
here's a quick message from our sponsor
who's the responsible for this video
again here at geek culture we've tested
plenty of chairs but Secret Life gaming
chairs remain one of our favorites
whether it's for work or play they feel
great to lean back against with the
ergonomic features offering support for
the whole body from the head and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this makes a format function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
my friend right here boom
I think we got ourselves a winner look
at that look at the separation the bokeh
just how that pops Zacky pops is the
bunny on the iPhone I'm not seeing a lot
of Pop from Zacky on that again AI
coming into play you're getting that
natural bouquet you're all Plus on top
of that you're getting that AI bouquet
it's going to simulate this the Leica 75
1.25 knock Deluxe lens how much is this
lens in Singapore that lens is roughly
around 18 19
000 what do you think Zacky
this
for a 19 000 lens
I'll go for the lens
now of course with the xiaomi you can go
to 35 millimeter black and white mode
get that beautiful like Triax color to
it acros acros 2 deep contrast looking
sexy now with the iPhone you can't do
that but in the sub menu of the iPhone
when you go to edit
I can go right into Apple's editing
system here
and I can just give a little bit of
black and white like that let's see how
it looks Noir and Noir what do we think
guys look at that who's the winner who
do you think is the winner here we're
gonna show on the screen anyway because
you can't really see it on the phone but
got to give it the xiaomi has more of
that look that Vibe again the temples
lights are closed Zaki why are the
temple lights closed so early but I just
love the Black and Whites coming out of
the xiaomi the like a collaboration
again give you that more of that
filmesque look that filmesque Vibe you
can do it with the iPhone but it just
takes a few more steps you know here's
the thing with apple they're not into
all these quote-unquote gimmick things
when you do photography but they are fun
to use and I think with the xiaomi it
does make it a little bit more enjoyable
hi sir hey can we take a quick photo of
you on your bike with the lights like
this
yeah we'll see one bite we'll see one
bike yeah you uh okay
awesome did I just take one over here
with you here we go thank you sir
got the nice light coming in the
background the tonality yeah it looks
great the guy looks great handsome guy
which one you like better this one
xiaomi yeah very good very good all
right guys as you saw there from the
sample photos the video and just this
experience here in Chinatown tonight
this battle is a lot closer than I
thought it was going to be I mean at the
beginning of this video I said to myself
look I think the xiaomi 13 Pro is going
to really beat the iPhone when it comes
to photography fair enough
but these are neck and neck in a lot of
ways some of you might like the iPhone
better than the xiaomi and some of you
might like the xiaomi better than the
iPhone you know with our schweika guy
there on the bike
I Gotta Give It to the xiaomi but
sometimes the iPhone range Supreme now
when it comes to video of course the
iPhone will be better than the xiaomi I
think this is something that we noticed
in our initial xiaomi 13 Pro review that
the video quality isn't quite it isn't
there as much as the photography portion
of the camera system is hopefully xiaomi
does improve this in future phones out
there even with the 13 Ultra that I'm
seeing online with other reviewers it's
still pretty much the same video quality
that's where the iPhone still shines
once again if you want a phone that does
everything well I'm still going to tell
you to go for the iPhone 14 pro Max but
if you want something that really excels
in photography then the 13 Pro from
xiaomi may be the way to go anyway those
are my thoughts on this comparison let
me know your thoughts in the comments
section below which phone did you like
best which one would you pick up but in
the meantime if you like this comparison
check out more of our phone comparisons
our phone battles right there